maintenant notre premier rêve de gagner
la francophonie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un grand honneur à nous d'être
présente ici pour défendre notre pays et
j'espère bien qu'on va pouvoir aller en
finale aussi
[Musique]
franchement on connaît pas beaucoup nos
adversaires on s'attendait à rien quand
nous sommes venus ici mais on se prépare
bien on va les regarder maintenant et on
va préparer j'espère bien qu'on va
gagner
il y a environ 8 ou 9 clubs en première
division toutes les filles ici de
l'équipe nationale jouent dans la
première division bien sûr on joue dans
différentes équipes mais
nous avons tous joué avec le même coach
donc ça c'est bien elle nous connaît on
s'entraîne presque tous les jours et
même au Liban on s'entraîner tous les
jours donc on s'est bien préparé ah non
tout le tout le toute notre
peau que et en
il y a une très grande responsabilité de
montrer une belle image de notre pays et
de jouer de bien jouer
[Musique]